let's compare kinetic energies in a two
particle one-dimensional collision in
different reference frames so we could
have one reference frame in which
particle one is coming in and particle
two is moving like that and in
particular so we can call this the
ground frame and now let's consider the
center of mass frame and in the center
of mass frame let's remind you that when
we have two different reference frames
the velocity will call this the ground
frame G in the ground frame is equal to
the velocity of the object will actually
write it this way just unprimed v1 the
velocity in the center-of-mass frame so
this is the velocity in the CM frame
plus the relative velocities between the
frames and that's why that's the
velocity of the center of mass so this
was our rule for describing how
velocities change in different reference
frames and so we can draw the picture in
the center of mass frame v1 initial
Prime and v2 initial Prime now let's
compare kinetic energies in these
different frames so we know that the
kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame is just one-half m1 v1 initial
squared prime put the prime there plus
one-half to initial prime squared
kinetic energy in the center-of-mass
frame how do we calculate the kinetic
energy in the lab frame well that's a
little bit more complicated and we'll
need a little algebra to start that so
let's put kinetic energy in the ground
frame we know is one-half m1 v1 initial
squared plus one-half m2 v2 initial
squared now what I have to do is use the
law the velocity relationship and this
is going to take a little bit of algebra
we have m1 all right
1 prime plus vcn and remember that any
quantity squared is the dot product B
dot B so I'm gonna adopt this with
itself
B one initial prime plus V center of
mass and I have the second term which
looks identical to this first term I'll
write it all the way down here one-half
m2 v2 the initial prime plus BC M vector
dot scaler dot product of V 2 initial
prime plus B cm now when you take a dot
product
remember there's four terms here there's
v1 prime dot v1 prime which is just v1
prime squared
there's V center of mass dot V center of
mass so that's V center of mass squared
and then there's the cross term and
because they're identical there's a
factor of two and it will be repeated
below so the kinetic energy in the
ground frame is 1/2 and 1 so we'll take
v1 i prime dotted with itself
that's v1 i prime squared we have the
cross term which is a factor of 2 which
will cancel this
so the cross term is m1 that cancelled
the factor of 2 v1 i prime dot b cm plus
the BCM with itself so that's one-half
m1 b cm squared now i have exactly the
same thing on the next one so we'll
write that down one-half b 2i prime
squared plus m2 v2 AI prime dot b CM
that's the same in both plus one-half m2
v cm squared now let's look carefully
what we have we have one-half m1 v1
prime squared this is an m2 one-half m2
v2 i prime squared
so we have one-half m1 v1 i prime
squared plus one-half m2 v2 I prime
squared and you're already noticing
that's the kinetic energy in the
center-of-mass frame we have the total
mass one-half m1 plus m2 v cm squared I
can just put a little check to show
which terms are done so far and now
here's the interesting one
we have m1 v1 I prime plus m2 b2 i prime
dot v cm that represents this term in
this term added together but recall that
the center of mass reference frame is
defined by the condition that the total
momentum in that frame is zero so this
term is zero and thus we get that the
kinetic energy in the ground frame is
equal to the kinetic energy in the
center-of-mass frame plus one-half m1
plus m2 times V cm squared and that's
how kinetic energy is in different
reference frames and the next thing
we'll look at is how that changes when
we have a collision